um well what else we got boys speaking
of cte you want to talk about uh antonio
brown oh my god what do you what is your
thought on that akash his story is the
coach bruce arians tried to make him
play with an injury like he told him he
was hurt and bruce arian's like nah go
back out there and he was like i can't
i'm hurt and then bruce area and said if
you don't go back out there you're off
the team and so that's why he quit in
the fashion in which he quit what did he
do
he antonio brown uh took off his
jersey and shoulder pads mid game on the
sideline walked to the locker room
shirtless and as he's in the end zone
hyped up the crowd the jets crowd the
away crowd he's a buck tampa bay
buccaneer and then just basically quit
the team
[ __ ] raising the one as he runs into
the tunnel it's a hilarious video
and but what's the deal like if he's
that injured why the [ __ ] can't he uh
why can he why can he run and jump that
was my thought if you're so hurt you're
raising your arms you're running and
jumping right how hard are you yeah he
didn't look that hurt
yeah so i don't know if that's his story
tom brady and bruce arians apparently
saying like hey
uh he's off the team but like be kind to
him and he's not in like the best mental
state like just be kind to somebody that
was a good responsible yeah yeah yeah
cause it also completely like they can't
say [ __ ] what do you mean but you're
you're saying hey be nice to this guy's
you know we don't know what his mental
health struggles are but you're calling
the guy crazy you're saying we had a
[ __ ] crazy person on our team in his
house wasn't he living with you yes
yes
tom had a crazy person in his house yeah
anything to win he really will he put
his kids lives at stake
he's a crazy person walking around the
house shirtless i heard the week leading
up to the super bowl last year against
kansas city he sent his entire family
away
and was just like no the house is mine
i'm studying film a non-stop i gotta get
better
i gotta get better at this i've been
negotiating with my wife nah like
like i shorty i gotta be great like beat
it you know what i mean like
i don't i really gotta be better at this
man here's two plane tickets go over you
want go wherever you want take another
guy i don't give a [ __ ] no no
no no
i'm not there yet i just got married
take another gay guy there you go
take that another kid yeah yeah yeah
another one not me yeah not me
yeah it's just it's just
ah man
this is weird that that it's uh yeah
it's sad but it's also dude tom brady's
[ __ ] perfect he handles it all
perfectly just say it like that and not
be like you know he quit on the team
that's what the easy way to go and then
to say like hey let's all be nice to him
and then they end up winning the game
right yeah they came down 24 10 when he
left and they ended up winning 28 24 or
28 27 wasn't it a game-winning drive
with like under two minutes left he went
like 93 yards completely tom brady tom
brady like his 68th game-winning drive
in his career or some [ __ ] like
something 44 years old it's almost like
it's almost like he needed a little bit
of uh
yeah a little bit of something exciting
yeah he needed the flu someone caught my
mouth and they lost the game before and
had like their second best receiver got
injured they're running they're starting
running back got injured like mad people
got hurt in the game before and they
lost and yeah
it's we're fine it's 24 2010 but it's
the jets i've destroyed the jets my
whole career are you willing to admit
he's greater than jordan yet no he's not
this kind of nothing
i think i think he's greater in every
way he's great that's what i'm saying
he's greater in every single one in
color
no he's like raiders like an athlete
he's a better leader i think he's like a
better person better human being for
sure
better looking but jordan handsome but
tom brady hey jordan probably got a
better body jordan i know jordan got a
way better body
not even close
but uh i don't know jordan's kind of
jordan
you don't think jordan's handsome i
think he's definitely aged better not
even questioning brady aged better oh
yeah jordan looks like [ __ ] now yeah but
we'll see once he's brady's retired yeah
you know for for four years but
or five years brady gonna be gorgeous
forever doug yeah he might be that
[ __ ] agent gracefully yeah
jordan i think antonio brown has actual
like mental health yeah cte for sure 1
000 ct is not even that's he does i just
attribute it all to and it was the hit
on
by vaughn
in the playoff game i remember watching
that dirty hit yeah dirty hit and ever
since then no [ __ ] the guy has not been
the same mentally but you think he's
been more pro concussion can make that
happen i think if it's vicious enough
and if you watch the the replay of this
hit this [ __ ] is filthy
that's the hit that looks kind of crazy
he's down basically unconscious let's
see the replay so he goes up misses it
oh yeah he's a what 500 pounds of force
look at this
i mean what a piece of [ __ ] yeah but
also roethlisberger with the hospital
pass right there yes yeah he hung him
out to dry for sure
but that straight to his head yeah dude
and you know what shoulder straight to
the head if he had caught that pass he'd
be able to handle that hit yeah but the
fact that he didn't catch it was a bit
too high too if it was a little it was a
bad pass but like if he had caught it
he'd at least brace for impact yes but
when you don't catch it i don't think
clay is done yeah yeah yeah isn't that
interesting
no that was brutal yeah and i truly
don't think he's been the same since
then well yeah yeah i think one head
injury like can especially because it's
a one head injury compounded by all the
other little hits yeah yeah they're
saying with nfl in general is like ct's
like the
it's like the chronic the micro the
micro concussions whatever they call
them like the little hits but yeah
that's why they're worried about linemen
the most because it's just a lot of
little
yeah but it's never linemen that are
like killing their wives and [ __ ] like
that i think i think it is true really
yeah there's at least not famous enough
yeah
but the lineman should be the worst
right because every single play you're
doing a headbutt right yeah whereas the
linebacker
how many tackles you think you're
getting the game oh linebackers have 100
tackles a year no problem and then
you're getting in there every like
junior seau one of the greatest
linebackers ever he died i think he
committed suicide and his family thought
he had cte and he was a guy i mean these
are [ __ ] in their every play like the
lineman hit every play too but you're
the next line of defense and you're all
over the field yep yep yep yep and it's
probably just bigger impact too yeah
you're running full speed they're
running full speed do you think abs
meltdown affects the league
no no the league keeps going and it
keeps growing
yeah i keep watching i feel kind of
guilty but i'm not gonna stop watching
that's what i'm saying how many people
like you are feeling a little like yeah
this is getting weird
no i gotta football weirdly
really yeah i usually like as a kid i
knew every football player brett favre
was there like i was into football and
then slowly over time i was like yo i
don't like watching
people just app like it's gonna
someone's gonna die in the field and i
just don't want to be a part of interest
in a weird way and is it because it it's
disingenuous
like with boxing or like fight sports
you know what they're entering and this
feels like they're kind of being lied to
well the nfl hit it a long time like
cigarettes yeah yeah so if nfl just came
out and we're like yo this [ __ ] is wild
dangerous and you're most likely going
to get cte and if you choose to do this
that's up to you then maybe it would
absolve the guilt a little bit a little
bit but like they encourage kids to get
into the game and all that [ __ ] yeah
like i would never encourage my kid to
get into mma
you know what i mean i'd be like you can
learn how to like spar and [ __ ] about
karate you probably wanted your kid to
do some sort of self-defense right
you don't want them sparring hard and
getting cracked in the head twice a week
every week
would you let your kid play football
yeah tackle football yeah yeah
i mean if he was a actual man yeah 16
though i say wait till like 16. 14 15
maybe
i don't know nah i don't i really don't
think playing [ __ ] peewee makes you a
player some kids don't hit each other
hard bro nah they be hitting but like i
don't think you actually develop as a
player like i don't think ladainian
thomas and whoever would be like dude if
it wasn't for pewdie football what i
would have been here what what do you
mean i think i'm the only person here
who played tackle football he played it
i think he played at a high level right
yeah dove got beat up by some middle
schoolers and he's got a story oh we
played flag but then when we started in
high school and you played against some
of the schools in la
you knew like you knew kids that played
pop warner and they it hurt i couldn't
believe the hits that i took i'm just
like i just did this to [ __ ] wear the
jersey to school get the girls and you
play defense yeah well i've tried wide
receiver i couldn't catch a ball for
[ __ ] right but they didn't have those
gloves back then and then i was like
that was it yeah
it was definitely the gloves yeah yeah
yeah yeah
there was some sticky guys would add it
too come on anyway did your nose stick
out of the mask
the lyman one where it was like the bar
across the face could you not play
lineman because you just started trying
to kiss the guys by putting your nose in
this nuzzle do you think you have ctabs
no but i got cacao with that almost
cheap move that gotta be cte right there
yeah
it hurt and they said there's research
like an average number of concussions
that leads to cte is like 16 or 17.
like these guys have had that many and
they don't report them so yeah
[ __ ] yeah i mean i'm gonna keep
watching yeah i don't hold the league
responsible at all at this point if they
come out and say it it's still not going
to change anything the players at this
point know what they're getting into i
feel so bad for people who didn't know
what they were getting into and the
league isn't really taking care of
retired players like they cut their
benefits wherever they can league is a
it's like the most ruthless corporation
they make money i think they're worried
about cut costs everywhere i think
that's the big thing oh you admit it and
then boom the water falls ooh that's
interesting it's gonna go down you know
what i mean yeah could you
yeah like does that cancer sponsorship
go yeah because like ufc has amazing
sponsors and they're honest about what
they are what they're doing but even if
you look at the sponsorship between like
nfl and ufc it's different yeah you know
state farm is different insurance is
going to sponsor cte yeah
landscape will yeah yeah
well different ad budget yeah that's
interesting is nfl the most profitable
league in the world it is well for sure
in america i think and the most valuable
team is the cowboys yeah over like man
city and all man united all that wow
really yeah wow
according and you gotta look at the
schedule too it's like
they play
17 games a year now yeah 17. compare
that to what do soccer teams play
more than 17 right yeah way more so it's
like baseball's 162.
basketball's 82. yeah like you're doing
a fraction
of the games and you're still making
more money dude they did christmas day
ratings
numbers and i wish i remembered but i
want to say
the nfl is not a christmas day they
never promote christmas thanksgiving is
their day the nba tried to take
christmas
this year they had two football games
they got like 29 million viewers each
and then the highest rated basketball
game was something like 12 million those
numbers aren't exactly something like
that it's just crazy yeah yeah they
don't even we're not even trying we're
dominating yeah it's a more enjoyable
sport to watch on tv the excitement and
with groups and barbecues you don't need
barbecues for basketball games yeah
finals it's gotta be playoffs or finals
a football game that's reasonably close
is
an awesome game to watch
because
of how they've curated the watching
experience from home they actually
haven't done a good job live no football
live kind of stinks you don't have great
seats it sucks and
if you don't have a like a real like
stake in one of the teams like just
being a casual at a football game it's
like if the weather stinks you're kind
of cold
you can't see the um
you can't see the movement of the ball
like a four-yard run on tv looks okay oh
yeah
from the back corner
you can't see depth yeah like it doesn't
mean anything for you if it's like a
interesting perspective though when we
were at the celtics game we got to go
shout out to randy again but we got to
go uh sit in the
in the suite
and we were in the center suite meaning
like
we were right in the center and we could
see both benches as well it's probably
like the best [ __ ] suite in in the
house and
you'd think a suite you'd be kind of far
away from the action and it wouldn't be
as enjoyable to watch i looked at the
the jumbotron less
the sweet level to me was the exact
level that the cameras are for when you
watch the game at home
so and since your center
you're watching the action like evenly
yeah it was [ __ ] perfect yeah yeah
and and uh but i think that's what the
nfl has created oh yeah like at home you
really feel like this intimate show
don't like going to games i think
the second time in history the as of
earlier this year away teams had a
winning record against home teams
because their home field advantage
doesn't really exist anymore
like the only thing it does is refs are
still more inclined to give you calls
but like
yeah dude cowboys games it's not that
loud because the hardcore fans are like
i can still just watch yeah it's way too
[ __ ] expensive they got these
personal seat licenses that cost crazy
money you have to pay every single year
no matter what and it's just not worth
it yeah it's not worth it yeah i i would
rather watch at home they got the
commentary down they got the replay down
they got yeah they just figured out and
basketball it's uh
i don't know man the energy's just not
there i think what kills basketball the
most and i love basketball live but
football live has this a bit but
basketball the end of the game bogs down
so much we're fouling all the time i
love basketball live i was saying
basketball on tv on tv yeah yeah i think
the last 30 seconds of a game takes 12
minutes yeah yeah yeah yeah i hear you i
hear you yeah for some reason yeah i
think it's just because it is so few
games it makes it more of an event
that's when there is a game that also is
that's also true every game matters yeah
yeah
every game matters like the playoffs the
whole season yeah yeah no that's true
that's true and the players know that so
they're not half-assing it like you
could tell when the players step it up
in basketball yeah absolutely like the
defense is getting real people diving
for balls and [ __ ] but game 73
is 37 year old lebron really going to
kill himself in 1973. like halfway
through the season all of a sudden kyrie
uh maybe i might play away games now
yeah yeah he's like
the coaster yeah that coasted 100
percent
you